die zahl der positiven corona tests
sinkt rapide
trotzdem soll es beim shutdown bleiben
auch wenn die kultusminister innen
eigentlich schulen schrittweise öffnen
wollen deutschland im tiefkühl models
überall frost in nürnberg frieren viele
sogar drinnen weil ein heizkraftwerk
brennt der sturm aufs kapitol und das
dilemma der us-republikaner oder contra
trump im senat beginnt das
amtsenthebungsverfahren
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten am dienstag die
vom sport hat norbert lehmann dabei ein
stück von mir
es wird wohl nichts mit lockerungen so
der trend vor dem bund länder treffen
morgen in berlin
darin ist man sich offenbar einig also
vorerst keine rückkehr ins normale leben
zumindest nicht jetzt zur mitte des
monats
dabei geht die zahl der neuinfektionen
weiter zurück eigentlich ermutigend dass
rk ii meldet heute rund 3900 80 neue
ansteckungen binnen 24 stunden vor einer
woche wurden 6114 neuinfektionen
gemeldet die sieben tage incidents pro
100000 einwohner sinkt erstmals unter 75
andererseits aber wächst die sorge über
eine dritte welle durch die
hochansteckenden virus mutationen aus
großbritannien und südafrika
thomas reichert berichtet am tag vor dem
treffen es zumindest so viel klar die
aussichten sind ähnlich ungemütlich wie
das berliner wetter in einem
beschlussentwurf von bund und ländern
heißt es die kontakt beschränkungen
sollten in den nächsten wochen
grundsätzlich beibehalten werden
aus sorge vor den hoch ansteckenden
neuen varianten des virus und selbst das
ist einigen fast noch zu wenig
eigentlich müsste jetzt verschärft
werden wir sind zwar einen absinkenden
trend bei den gesandt fällen aber die
zahl der viren die deutlich gefährlicher
sind aus england die mutation aus
england aber aus südafrika die wirken
wie turbo viren verbreiten sich sehr
viel schneller die geltenden shutter und
regeln sollen nach dem entwurf deshalb
verlängert werden private zusammenkünfte
sollen beschränkt bleiben auf eine
weitere person medizinische masken
bleiben pflicht den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und geschäften und
private reisen sollen weiter unterlassen
werden
umstritten zwischen bund und ländern ist
noch wie lange die regeln gelten sollen
ziemlich unumstritten aber ist dass
kitas und schulen mit als erste öffnen
sollen
darauf drängen die kultusminister und
nicht nur die
wir werden morgen die frage beantworten
müssen und wir werden sie für
schleswig-holstein definitiv auch beamte
worden wann werden kitas und schulen
wieder geöffnet niemand kann mehr
erklären
du kannst du viel tablets anschaffen wie
du willst dass ein distanz unterricht
dass ein herz für kinder ein guter
lernort ist daneben gibt es aus mehreren
bundesländern die idee ist so genannte
stufen pläne
sie sollen abhängig vom
infektionsgeschehen lockerungen oder
verschärfungen vorhersehbarer machen die
hoffnung man einigt sich morgen im
kanzleramt auf einen bundesweiten plan
es bleibt tatsächlich auch das ziel
einen solchen plan zu haben um letztlich
dann auch noch mal ja die die zähne
zusammen beißen können und nicht
aufzugeben sondern zu sagen okay wir
müssen jetzt noch ein gewissen weg gehen
ein solcher stufenplan müsste auch
aufzeigen didier verantwortbar stück für
stück auch wieder das öffentliche leben
öffnen können vorgesehen ist auch dass
unternehmen ab februar
abschlagszahlungen von bis zu 100000
euro pro monat als überbrückungshilfe
erhalten sollen
so jedenfalls steht es im entwurf der
morgen wie immer erst noch beraten und
beschlossen werden muss ist jetzt der
zeitpunkt für lockerungen diese frage
wird gleich um halb acht bei zdf heute
live diskutiert mit fdp chef lindner und
mit professor thorsten leer der mit
seinem team einen kowitz simulator
entwickelt hat sie können fragen stellen
in unserer app und den social media
plattformen die südafrikanische krone
variante macht auch österreichs
regierung immer mehr sorgen kanzler kurz
erklärte heute wer aus tirol ausreisen
will braucht dazu einen negativen test
mit 300 fällen sei der ausbruch in tirol
der größe der zeit bekannte in der eu
die testpflicht gilt zunächst für zehn
tage
das bundesland wehrte sich tagelang
vehement gegen eine abschottung gestern
hatte wien bereits eine reisewarnung für
tirol verhängt ja das ist ja schon ein
ungewöhnlicher schritt britta hilpert in
wien dass ein land sein eigenes
bundesland quasi abriegelt
ungewöhnlich aber notwendig und es war
das maximal mögliche mit dieser
landesregierung die hatte sicher tage
lang dagegen gewehrt selbst schärfere
maßnahmen zu verhängen wie zum beispiel
eine verlängerung des locker und sie
wollte unbedingt am montag ihre läden
und friseure wieder aufsperren wie ganz
österreich und so kann man jetzt in
innsbruck und anderswo in tirol
weiterhin einkaufen und sich die haare
schneiden lassen und erst ab freitag
muss man einen negativen test vorweisen
sollte man die landesgrenzen
überschreiten wollen
ziel dieser abschottung und der warnung
vor reisen nach tirol ist es natürlich
die mutanten nach möglichkeit in tirol
einzugrenzen zu behalten so zu sagen
aber die zahl der auspendler die zahl
der pendler ist sehr groß auch nach
bayern und so kann man jetzt schon an
den grenzen beobachten dass verschärft
kontrolliert wird und wir werden auch
weiter beobachten ob weitere maßnahmen
folgen
vielen dank britta nach wien und jetzt
zum dauerfrost in deutschland das geht
noch die ganze woche so zweistellige
minusgrade sind keine seltenheit
die eiseskälte macht gerade in nürnberg
besonders vielen menschen zu schaffen
hier rief die stadt den katastrophenfall
aus denn nach einem großbrand in einem
heizkraftwerk fällt die fernwärme aus in
der kälte zu hause sitzen jetzt rund
15.000 einwohner im südwesten ein
problem auch für betriebe und
pflegeheime petra neubauer
sie haben an diesem eisigen abend keine
guten nachrichten für die menschen in
zwei nürnberger stadtteilen
es kann natürlich dazu kommen dass die
bewohner in der nacht eine etwas kältere
wohnung haben als gewöhnlich schuld ist
ein feuer im nürnberger großkraftwerk
darf hat derart gewütet dass die anlage
wohl wochenlang für die
fernwärmeversorgung ausfällt bedeutet
heizen nur noch auf sparflamme
mit diesen einschränkungen könnte
zumindest der betrieb der kliniken und
altenheime weiterlaufen als ersatz für
das ausgefallene kraftwerk sind mobile
heizanlagen angefordert für frierende
menschen 3000 hotelbetten reserviert
viele aber haben sich schon eigene
rezepte zurechtgelegt warme suppe kocht
und hrt und dann passt es ja ein
kaminofen und kann da noch ein bisschen
dazu führen wenn es jetzt nötig wäre
auch bei verwandten einquartieren ist
möglich sagt die stadt die kontakt
beschränkungen wegen corona würden in
dieser notlage ausnahmsweise nicht
gelten
eine herausforderung ist das
winterwetter auch für viele die im auto
unterwegs sind
hunderte werden sich wohl noch lange an
die eisige nacht auf der autobahn
erinnern
bei bielefeld waren auf der a2 zeitweise
beide fahrtrichtungen gesperrt
lkw standen quer die reisenden saßen in
der falle
gabi handelt berichtet so hatte sich
wohl niemand seinen feierabend
vorgestellt bei klirrender kälte mussten
hunderte von autofahrern auf der a2 bei
bielefeld in ihren wagen ausharren und
dort auf hilfe warten reaktionen
das führungs wärmen
das war s wir liegen ja überall links
und rechts lkw eine straße und womit
zwar überhaupt ist ihr abgeschleppt
werden damit weitergehen kann
tatsächlich haben viele lkw-fahrer das
witterungsbedingte fahrverbot von
gestern ignoriert und so maßgeblich zum
kilometer langen stau beigetragen weil
sie auf spiegelglatter fläche schnell
ins schlingern gerieten auch der
abschleppwagen pfarrer kilian nordbrock
kommt kaum noch durch
egal wie es kommt die steigenden kosten
pkw stehen natürlich dann dazwischen
kommen auch nicht weg sind um farbe
arbeitsstelle zur zeitung
kurz danach heißt es auch für ihn nichts
geht mehr auf der a2 auch ein
abschleppdienst kommt hier an seine
grenzen und erst 20 stunden später löst
sich der stau
ganz langsam auf in den usa
dort beginnt gerade im moment der
impeachment prozess gegen ex-präsident
trump historisch allein schon deshalb
weil es sein zweiter ist
darum geht's die demokraten werfen trump
anstiftung zum aufruhr vor und meinen
damit seine rede unmittelbar vor der
stürmung des kapitols vor knapp fünf
wochen für das verfahren wird der senat
jetzt quasi zum gerichtssaal es gibt
anklage verteidigung und senatoren und
senatorinnen als geschworene von palo
die sicherheitskräfte rund um das
kapitol sind in höchster
alarmbereitschaft denn hinter den zäunen
geht es für die demokraten um nicht
weniger als die zukunft ihres landes im
zweiten impeachment gegen donald trump
wollen sie beweise vorliegen die es noch
nicht zu sehen gab es werden starke
beweise
einige davon werden nur jeder senator
demokraten republikaner sollte sich dem
prozess mit der ernsthaftigkeit
annähernd die er verdient aufstachelung
zum aufruhr lautet die anklage
viele der senatorinnen und senatoren
standen am 6 januar selbst todesängste
aus als der wütende mob des kapitols
lotte im zentrum steht die frage hat der
präsident mit seinen worten zu gewalt
beigetragen
wenn ihr nicht kämpft wie der teufel
habt ihr kein land mehr
dieser aufforderung zum kampf sei
symbolisch gemeint sagen trumps anwälte
die das amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen
einen präsidenten der nicht mehr im amt
ist für absurd halten sowie viele
republikaner
das ist politische vergeltung ich
fürchte wir bewegen uns auf sehr dünnem
eis
trotzdem wird der senat das verfahren
heute wohl mit einfacher mehrheit als
rechtmäßig durchwinken bevor anklage und
verteidigung in den kommenden tagen ihre
standpunkte erläutern
für einen schuldspruch bräuchten die
demokraten eine zwei drittel mehrheit
mindestens 17 republikaner müssten gegen
tram stimmen
da scheint unwahrscheinlich
ebenso wie sich der ex-präsident bislang
weigert unter eid auszusagen
jetzt viel charme von weiteren
politischen ämtern auszuschließen
müssten die demokraten bei einem
freispruch erst einmal aufgeben
fragen wir unseren us korrespondenten
elmar theveßen
elmar große erfolgschancen hat das
amtsenthebungsverfahren ja wohl nicht
warum findet es trotzdem statt ja die
demokraten wollen im grunde um zwei
signale senden dass eine passiert hier
heute die frage ob das ganze
verfassungsgemäß ist also ob ein
präsident sich für seine taten
verantworten muss auch wenn er gar nicht
mehr im amt ist ein sehr wichtiges
signal denn wenn das nicht so wäre dann
würde das ja bedeuten an präsident kann
den zwischenraum zwischen wahl und
amtseinführung des nachfolgers
eigentlich alles machen ohne sich dafür
verantworten zu müssen egal was jetzt
bei diesem prozess heraus kommt und das
andere signal
vielleicht noch wichtiger wie nah die
demokratie hier an den abgrund gekommen
ist und das geht besonders gut glaube
ich bei einem prozess der gewissermaßen
am tatort stattfindet hier wird gezeigt
werden von den demokraten in den
nächsten tagen dass hetze das lügen dass
das fortlaufende untergraben der
demokratischen institutionen diese
demokratie an den rand gebracht haben ob
das signal dann nach ende des prozesses
im land auch wirklich ankommt das werden
wir es wissen wenn wir sehen ob beide
seiten republikaner und demokraten in
den nächsten monaten bereit sind zwar
politisch in der sache zu streiten aber
am ende doch wenn es ums wohl das ganze
des ganzen geht das wohl des landes
miteinander zusammenzuarbeiten
die hintergründe zum impeachment gegen
donald trump von immer thesen vielen
dank dafür
in myanmar geht das militär nach seinem
putsch mit zunehmender härte vor
jetzt soll die armee die parteizentrale
der festgenommenen regierungschefin
augen sanssouci durchsucht und zerstört
haben das meldet die partei auf facebook
trotz verbot gehen die proteste auf den
straßen weiter
demonstrierende fordern die freilassung
von aung san suu kyi
die polizei setzt inzwischen
wasserwerfer ein auch schüsse sollen
gefallen sein
noch einmal zurück zum thema corona um
9,3 prozent ist der deutsche export im
vergangenen jahr wegen der pandemie
eingebrochen
gewaltig und doch nicht so hoch wie
befürchtet da vor allem die nachfrage
aus china zum jahresende wieder
angezogen hat
für dieses jahr geht der
außenhandelsverband bga von einem
deutlichen plus aus
der kampf gegen korona und
wissenschaftler vieler
forschungsrichtungen weil das erbgut der
viren sich bereits im abwasser
nachweisen lässt arbeiten experten in
der ganzen welt daran dort das kogit 19
infektionsgeschehen möglichst früh
nachzuweisen
bereits kleine mengen viren können in
kläranlagen aufgespürt werden
experten haben in frankfurt am main noch
vor der zweiten infektionswelle eine
erhöhte viren konzentration im abwasser
registriert stefan schlosser über die
chancen des frühwarnsystems alles was
1,8 millionen menschen aus frankfurt und
umgebung ausscheiden landet hier im
klärwerk im abwasser lassen sich schon
kleinste mengen an viren nachweisen auch
das saas kauf 2 virus durch regelmäßige
proben untersuchungen mit moderner
diagnostik können forscher der tu
darmstadt erkennen ob die virus
konzentration steigt oder fällt der
größte vorteil den ich sehe ist dass wir
gesehen haben in unseren daten dass wir
einfach fünf bis zehn tage früher
anstiege erkennen können und damit eben
auch schneller reagieren könnten auf und
maßnahmen ergreifen infektions ausbrüche
lassen sich so frühzeitige erkennen und
auch räumlich eingrenzen den proben an
verschiedenen stellen des kanalnetzes
genommen werden
das funktioniert schon bei einer
inzidenz ab etwa fünf bis zehn und
erfasst ein infektionsgeschehen bereits
dann wenn die infizierten selbst davon
noch nichts wissen
ein ganz großer vorteil patienten die
keine symptome haben würden ja
normalerweise nicht zum klassischen test
gehen aber auch scheint tun sie das
virus trotzdem also man hat einige
vorteile mit solch einer methode
durchgehend sequenzierung können die
forscher auch mutationen von saas kopf
zwei im abwasser nachweisen schneller
und genauer die britische variante haben
sie bereits gefunden
zeit ist ein entscheidender faktor bei
der virus bekämpfung je früher gezielte
maßnahmen zur eindämmung ergriffen
werden können desto besser
das frühwarnsystem aus dem abwasser
funktioniert jetzt bräuchte es geld und
personal um es möglichst flächendeckend
zu installieren
eine studie der humboldt uni und des
zentrums für europäische
wirtschaftsforschung
mindestens zwei demonstrationen der
sogenannten querdenker innen wurden
demnach zu super spreading events bis zu
21.000 infektionen hätten verhindert
werden können wenn kundgebungen in
leipzig und berlin abgesagt worden wären
zehntausende menschen hatten dort
demonstriert oft ohne masken und abstand
viele waren in vollen bussen angereist
woher stammt das virus das deko oder
pandemie auslöste experten der
weltgesundheitsorganisation bhu haben
jetzt die gängigste theorie untermauert
wahrscheinlich von fledermäusen über ein
anderes wirtstier sei istanbul im
chinesischen wuchern auf den menschen
übergegangen
fast einen monat lang hat das team dort
nachgeforscht auch auf dem markt der als
übertragungs ort gilt die theorie das
virus stamme aus einem labor halten die
experten für extrem unwahrscheinlich
auch fanden sie keine hinweise auf
corona erkrankungen vor dezember 2009 10
und nun zu deren arbeit und wieder zu
den australian open in nevada sind ja
schon gestern gleich in der ersten runde
einige deutsche spielerinnen und spieler
ausgeschieden
das ging auch heute nacht so weiter jan
kampmann raus ebenso die deutsche nummer
2 jan lennard struff dafür überzeugt die
letzte deutsche im turnier
mona barthel ist überraschend die letzte
verbliebene deutsche in der
damenkonkurrenz gegen die italienerin
elisabetta carretto kann die 30-jährige
nach verlorenem ersten satz das spiel
fortan bestimmend und den zweiten satz
mit 6 4 für sich verbuchen
mit dem gleichen resultat für die
deutsche aus bad segeberg endet dann
auch der dritte durchgang nach diesem
erfolg wird mona barthel in der zweiten
runde gegen die tschechin karolina
mutter war im rollentausch die klare
außenseiterin seien gestern zu fischen
heute zu viel nebel bei der ski wm in
cortina d'ampezzo wurde nach der
kombination der frauen und dem super g
der männer als dritter wettbewerb nun
auch noch der frauen supergene
verschoben der soll nun am donnerstag
statt
die bayern auf dem weg zum sechsten
titelgewinn in einer saison
das hat vor ihnen nur der fc barcelona
geschafft die münchner besiegten gestern
abend bei der klub wm in katar im
halbfinale ägyptens rekordmeister allach
liegt eigentlich ist alles wie immer
robert lewandowski jubelt und trifft und
die bayern siegen halbfinale der klub wm
der zwei zu null siege gegen allach
ungefährdet zweimal der polnische
torjäger und auch die statements
hinterher klingen wie im 20
so stellen wir uns das vor etwas ist
dann aber doch anders gespielt wird vor
zuschauern in katar geschäft und
entertainment am golf für die bosse die
pandemie man eben keine bedrohung für
die bayern zählt das sportliche ziele
und jetzt haben wir eben diese chance
die bei uns unbedingt arbeiten wollten
nämlich das war die klub-wm auch
gewinnen
sixpack heißt also das ziel die kräfte
der bayern
auf den sechsten titel das risiko dass
sie dafür eingehen kann derzeit wohl
niemand genau einschätzen und im
endspiel am donnerstag treffen die
bayern auf den mexikanischen club tigers
danken
bei uns ist es ja eiskalt aber in kanada
ist es noch kälter
viel kälter in der provinz alberta sind
es tagsüber um minus 30 grad und östlich
der neben in saskatchewan steht der neue
kälterekord jetzt bei minus 48,9
kochendes wasser bleibt da auch nicht
lange heiß sieht wunderschön aus
da ist es bei uns ja schon fast
kuschelig dagegen wie kalt es heute
nacht wird ob und wo noch schwer fällt
das sagt uns gleich katja hornuf das
war's danke für ihr interesse
marietta slomka meldet sich um viertel
vor zehn mit dem heute-journal und wir
sind morgen wieder zur stelle um 19 uhr
einen schönen abend für sie
[Musik]
die narben meine damen und herren der
satellit sie zurzeit nicht nur wolken
sondern auch die schneeflächen ganz gut
so erkenntnis dass hier am niederrhein
oder auch richtung belgien niederlande
das weiß dass sich nicht bewegt das ist
der schnee heute viel ja noch schnee vor
allen dingen an der ostsee sonst war es
meist nur leichtes gefloppt
das wird sich jetzt in der nacht
allerdings ändern denn dann ziehen von
südwesten neue schneewolken auf und an
der ostsee gibt es weitere schneeschauer
dazwischen aber ist es zum teil klar und
dann wird es über den schneeflächen
wirklich eisig kalt die meisten von uns
haben so etwas noch nie erlebt
temperaturen zwischen minus 11 und minus
26 grad
und wenn es so tiefe temperaturen in der
nacht gibt da bleibt es natürlich auch
tagsüber zum teil beim strengen frost
zwischen minus zwölf und minus sieben
grad an den küsten von ost und nordsee
sind es minus 3 bis minus 1 grad und im
süden - 2 bis 0 grad über den süden
ziehen nämlich morgen schnee wolken
hinweg da könnten durchaus zehn bis 15
zentimeter neuschnee zusammenkommen
ähnlich groß können die neuschneemengen
durchaus auch in den schneeschauern an
der ostsee sei in den nächsten tagen
geht es sehr winterlich weiter es kommt
immer häufiger allerdings auch die sonne
zum vorschein
schönen abend noch